des recettes juste et universel c'est la
promesse de bruno lemaire chez nos
confrères d'europe 1 à l'issue de la
réunion des ministres des finances du g7
qui s'est déroulé les 4 et 5 juin
dernier dans la capitale britannique
au menu de cet accord qualifié de sans
précédent
un impôt minimum mondial sur les
sociétés est un engagement vers une
meilleure répartition des recettes
fiscales qui a pour objectif de lutter
contre les paradis fiscaux un accord qui
pour le moment jette les bases de la
réforme de la fiscalité internationale
si les ministres se sont entendus sur un
taux d'imposition à 15%
la france dit vouloir continuer le
combat pour augmenter cette contribution
le taux minimal que nous avons fixés
pour l'imposition des sociétés et à 15%
et je dis bien 15 % au minimum c'est un
point de départ et dans les mois qui
viennent nous allons nous battre pour
que ce taux d'imposition minimal à
l'impôt ces sociétés soient le plus
élevés possible
le combat va se poursuivre au g20 à l'
ocde
car plusieurs ong estiment ce taux trop
bas pour attac par exemple il s'agit
d'une avancée historique de 2,5 à 4
milliards d'euros au maximum en france
contre 16 milliards avec un taux de 21%
c'est ce que pourraient rapporter cet
impôt à l'hexagone selon les estimations
de l'organisation
un bénéfice à court terme qualifiée de
marginale
surtout ce faible taux continuera par
ailleurs de nourrir l'intense
concurrence fiscale qui se traduit
notamment par une course à la baisse des
taux nominaux et réels de l'impôt sur
les sociétés
les données de l' ocde montre que le
taux légal moyen de l'impôt sur les
sociétés a déjà fortement baissé
il a reculé de 7,4 points entre 2000 et
elle montre aussi que sur 36 pays
étudiés seuls 3 l'irlande le chili et la
hongrie présente un taux nominal d'impôt
sur les sociétés inférieures en 2021
les gouvernements des pays qui
présentent un taux nominal plus élevés
pourraient arguer qu'il faut s'aligner
sur ce taux de 15% avec pour conséquence
des pertes budgétaires importantes et
une aggravation de l'injustice fiscale
et sociale
même son de cloche du côté d'oxfam qui
indique que ce taux est bien trop bas
pour lutter contre les paradis fiscaux
une occasion manquée donc pour la france
selon les ong
c'est une occasion manquée puisque il y
a encore quelques semaines les états
unis proposer un taux effectif beaucoup
plus élevé à 21 % et la france l'a
soutenu du bout des lèvres que ce soit
15 ou 20 % finalement la difficulté sera
de convaincre les autres puissances du
g20 et notamment la chine ainsi que les
autres pays de l' ocde
le ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
a d'ailleurs précisé s'attendre je cite
un combat difficile et à une mise en
oeuvre de l'accord qui devrait prendre
deux à trois ans selon lui le processus
s'annonce donc long conséquence
l'application concrète de cette réforme
ne semble pas être pour après demain